if you spend any time apologizing to
employees [__] you that's so bold bit G
but I want to make a point I'm going to
explain what I mean and I and I went for
bold attention is the number one asset
the best leaders in the world take the
pressure and stops with them and they
convert it underneath them the worst
leaders in the world feel pressure and
pass that [__] down and a lot of you do
that real talk and you're like oh I'm
sorry I was stressed I lost you go in a
if you spend any time apologizing to
employees [__] you that's so bold bit G
I want to make a point listen if you're
excusing Behavior where you're yelling
and screaming at people with an apology
you are not as good as you think you are
I don't care how much money you're
making